Bleeba, bleeba, bleep, bleee!
Before this video begins, Origin PC has an exciting announcement!
Thats right,
they've announced their brand new thin laptops.
Oooh.
So thin...
They're thin, They're light,
But they're also equipped with real time,
ray tracing, technology
*noise*
If you dont know what that means
Don't worry I didn't either
It basically makes the games looks very Epic
The lights look good in the game
It looks actually pretty impressive. I am not gonna lie
😀😀😀
So check out their EVO 16S
It has a new narrow bezel design which makes a 16.1 inch display
possible on a 15 inch laptop body
That's pretty cool
Featuring up to RTX 2080
with MAX-Q graphics card inside
DAMN boy!
It's not thick, it's THIN!
That's right, this laptop is thin baby
but it still has that thick power
DAMN BOY!!!
DAMN that's... BIG...
screen.
the same real-time ray-tracing GPU now
if you want even more performance to
watch memes there eon 17x is their
desktop replacement laptop and can now
be customized with ray tracing as well
you want this you know you do with an
off to desktop class RTX 2080 graphics
card and an Intel Core i nine ninth
generation desktop processor damn boy
check out Origin PC link is in the
description you can also learn more
about our TX graphics on Origin PC
LWIAY
*Music*
YouTube Thank You Susan very epic of you
January it's always great to have
sponsors this video is sponsored by the
way hope you guys are having a great
month I'm having it it's a great month
I'm having a great time okay I get more
viewers than ever but the subreddit now
is at nine hundred and twenty thousand
subscribers Wow almost at a million can
we become the greatest subreddit of all
time high submission what a great name
I'm really glad I'm picked that name
very proud of that one it's on it's cool
the real one without a million all right
first mean I just hate when I see people
judge me off an insanely bias article or
even a made-up one discouraged face
first time I know how you feel ninja
it's okay it's only happened to me every
time it's okay I get it
PewDiePie when you gain ten million
subscribers so fast that your March
celebrating 70 million gets outdated in
a month
Peter pie suffering from success if you
guys could stop subscribing so quickly
that would be great because the campaign
hasn't even ended yet that's great
that's great can we hit 80 million
subscribers before nine days listen okay
they're like Pokemon sleeves March okay
if you're not owning them all don't come
complaining to me afterwards 80 million
KUB coming soon everyone I mean it looks
pretty slick anyway that's how mafia
really works
level one Kruk level hundred mafia boss
I'm gonna make you pump like that
copyrighted music remember when you
could add music into videos anyway the
entire fanbase when they see pewds with
the cat the ears on again guys I know
you're all word for me I know the
content is getting a little bit more
edgy there's nothing to worry about
these are different colored see it's
fine looks even
they even blend into the TV how epic is
that huh that's pretty cool nothing to
fear my friends me meeting pues back in
2015 at his book signing I was 11
oh I think I remember him actually he
like cut the line or something I was in
the best part of the experience was that
my mom best friend worked for the grow
and I got special access there you go
I do remember you you spoiled little
brat I'm just kidding thank you for
coming and supporting my book it's a
very nice book
I still get royalty so you guys want to
buy it I mean I'm not complaining please
appreciate the fact that Peter Pye dress
more formally for the meme Awards than
their New Year's party hey man it's all
about priorities what can I say
I actually wore the shirt but they never
own no one else were a short shirt so
I'm like it's kind of cold anyway that's
right I got bullied into it I don't only
get bullied online people I also get
bullied offline what can I say
Bowser Bowser sent Fred Fred date I mean
it's kind of scary how similar they look
I want them to collaborate oh my god I
had eaten two Bluto on there for over 20
years and I just noted there's a hidden
animal in the mountain oh my god Jesus
Christ
junga junga junga has it been there all
along how could we have been so blind
when you post subscribe to PewDiePie on
our PewDiePie submission subscribe to
feed it bye
when you tell that's like if I say
subscribe to Peter pie isn't it does it
make a difference please subscribe using
any other meme for me using this new
brand format so that he can achieve his
dream no get out of here Brian no one
cares about you getting Jaden animations
to host meme review getting Jaden to
animate me review yes cuz that takes no
effort at all ok Jaden all appreciate if
you can get it done by tomorrow thank
you
if I reach 80 million subscribers I'm
brick no I did not say that
there's no way I said that I can't tell
at this point what have I said god
dammit
well I guess it's time for the later to
return petition to add a timer on the TV
so we can see how much bride won and
brides who have to cut from the
shows video you guys want to know
everything don't you Jesus Christ
admitting you did something wrong other
youtubers did it
I really appreciate rice comes apology
video because it literally did
everything I would parody about an
apology video just deflect to other
people and not take any personal
responsibility 10 out of 10 apology rice
come I really appreciate it supposed to
be me what does that look like a version
version of me who is that person why
there's so many goddamn look-alikes
please hose me review actually wish it's
happening wait what there's so many fake
memes out there I can't tell anymore
well I guess it's setting stone a little
much
hosting meme review finally hit me up in
the DMS let's make this happen
very epic I am so proud of this
community Hey look at that bitch lasagna
finally now I can officially say I
didn't peek five years ago thank you it
that's awesome
very proud PewDiePie calls me out for
mystery unbox what is he talking about
PD PolyJet said nothing I just saw a
Papa Gloria the ultimate fusion
newscaster guys ride scum gave away
Amazon giftcards okay I don't know how
you can stay mad at things
did you not see the part where he so
generously gave away Amazon gift cards
you know what nothing says taking
responsibility after you get to then
just give away like a couple dollars
here you go now we're even
PewDiePie $1500 PC watching me yeah you
have a problem with a level 1 crook
level 399 month we are boss damn guys
for only 399 you can be a mafia boss as
well you can be just as epic guys I
think PewDiePie is a fan of unions now
I'm not supposed to have my own opinion
but yes yes I am a fan what can I say I
buy all the merch
pewds doesn't pay Brad Brad steel speed
speaker pewds
what a mean man Jesus Christ I found
pretty pie chair on the beach it does
this and it's authentic Italian plastic
oh yeah
oh this is heavy Italian design and
leather I don't think so only zero damn
that's impressive
guys I'm not subscribed to PewDiePie yet
because I'm waiting for t-series to get
close to say his subscriber count so I
can be an emergency subscribers when he
really needs it
Wow thank you so much I'm glad we have
at least some people that think ahead
what are you some Normie subscriber that
just subscribes shake my hand
yeah here it is what is this first the
market now this so long you can't hide
from the nine-year-olds Felix imagine
just taking a pic of your girlfriend and
Santa and seeing that Pierce is walking
in the back
imagine having a girlfriend I don't like
this stop when you're the best meme of
2018 but you don't even get a feature in
the meme Awards excuse me if Pierce
killed Hitler and Hitler killed himself
next main petition to make the TV screen
green so we can meme it on the subreddit
okay that should be easy
perfect poor Brad has to work two jobs
all these look-alikes goddamn nine year
olds during NEMA Wars meme review me
review option six well it turns out me
if you want anyway so stop thinking
you're cool and edgy for picking option
six option six will never be anything
ears of evil ears of purity that's right
this is our the Christian ears that's
why you can't see them they're too holy
Christian channel thank you level one
crook $5,000 milk oh wow is this the one
where he grows bigger I'm gonna make you
pump like that
level 35 bars damn Jesus Christ oh god
stop god stop please God stop just stop
just no more no more no more Obama's
please
tsunami T is silent honest the H is
silent island the S is silent q the U is
silent Pierce raise two hundred and
forty six thousand dollars for kids in
India the media his it's like that bird
box mean I've been living in Japan and
you know how everyone has been talking
about the photo every article uses for
Puetz yeah well this is the one Japan
chose Wow Thank You Japan arigatou
gozaimasu ooh a very good think this is
great I actually don't want to get
recognized in Japan so if Japan uses
this photo that would actually help me
out part of the reason I like it your
pet is the Lions because I never get
recognized please don't ruin Japan for
me please this guy made a beauty pie
themed ring with an NFC chip so it
subscribes you to PewDiePie
when you touch it to your phones what
you mean I can bro these people phones
and they'd actually subscribes to
beautify that is epic
patrika dare design found my engagement
ring if Pierce has no legs and Vox
bullies him then that means box foolish
disabled people well I clearly can't
read so I would say that's fairly
accurate thank you that's how mafia
works
wait so someone stole a pose any guts
26,000 outputs that's how much yeah
perfect in case you weren't sure that is
how mafia works
What Swedish youtuber
PewDiePie has gained millions of
subscribers by uploading frequent
commentary about what cooking oh my god
please did she actually answer that plea
she answered cooking oh it's this show
there no audio
frequent commentary about what yeah
video guy good gig PewDiePie very bad
thinking pause and cooking
oh I see you're a dumbass correct on
Suri's oh then look at that
nine-year-old in there
look at that nine-year-old right there
he was like I knew that I knew that shit
look at that guy is that guy five I can
do that Glaus yeah bye hey before I end
this video there's one thing I need to
do which is something that I never
thought I would do that's right
2019 who knows what's gonna happen next
because ah I'm a maverick now that's
right and I'm not afraid to say it
anymore I am a frickin maverick and
there's nothing you can do about it now
Logan asked me to wear no actually he
didn't ask he demanded that I would wear
this shirt and yes technically I didn't
have to do it I never agreed to do
anything but at the same time he I did
ask for help he did reach out he took it
he took it and I appreciate it you know
I think it's safe to say that I didn't
like Logan Paul before it was cool but I
think it goes to a point where he just
becomes a dead meme and I was starting
to feel bad for him and you can tell he
is genuinely changing and we all make
mistakes listen I'm not trying to make
it an apology video for you all I'm
saying is that someone that's personally
made a lot of mistakes that will
definitely haunt me for the rest of my
life I think the kid deserves a break I
do genuinely hope that with me showing
my epic support it doesn't let me down
and I hope that how do way it's so hard
to be nice why is it so fucking hard you
know I'm seeing patterns to show that
Logan Paul actually is bettering himself
and you know I want to encourage that I
hope I'm not like down at least either
way it doesn't matter here we go
everyone that's why
I'm a maverick everyone this is so weird
now excuse me I'm gonna jump into a
burning lava pit and that's it for me
for now see you guys next time
okay so
at the end of this I wanted to give a
shout out to the last two winners of the
PewDiePie uber simulator competitions so
you guys can see that the game is not dead
we had North Pole and the winner of this
theme was best / Onew so creative so
cool
second place went to Lady Fantasma 2 4 9
is that sponsor eagle really dope
submissions and then the next submission
the competition was it's real and the
winner was CommandingOfficer I'm legit
impressed by you guys I feel like the
fan base of this game has just taken on
its own which is really dope but I would
love to see some more people get into
this we have all kinds of submissions to
2018 like contagion by X Ruby game or
won this one it's really fun to see
download the game in description and
yeah let's do some cool stuff